next the award-winning writer James
Graham he's famous for his works on
stage and screen and in his new upcoming
work dear England turns his Focus to
football it's set for release this
summer and it tells the story of how
Gareth Southgate revived The Fortunes of
the national team it explores themes of
identity masculinity and racism as well
as the public backlash the team suffered
when taking on political and social
issues
James thanks for coming on the show and
let's start with the big news this week
about your new play about Gareth site
Southgate and what you call the gentle
Revolution he's been leading what's the
revolution you're talking about and why
did you want to turn that into a drama
I just love any any National Institution
or any system that at the time of its
greatest stress someone comes in and
disrupts it and changes it and they
either succeed or they fail and I think
if you think back it feels like a long
time ago because of the success of what
Gareth has done if you go back all the
way to 2016 it's like England was at the
absolute lowest end and then he goes on
this huge Journey where he wasn't just
talking about performance and results
I I think he was talking about something
much much bigger about spirit and soul
and character and identity what is it to
be a young English man in the 21st
century what is it to be English and and
the name of the play dear England is
based on this open letter that he wrote
in 2021 to to not just England fans but
to the nation and it was a really
political letter wasn't it was that the
inspiration for you that wasn't the
inspiration I've been thinking about
this for a few years almost ever since
and I don't want to reduce his mission
down to this but
if we remember England had never won a
penalty shootout in the World Cup before
we were like one of the worst in the
world at penalties at our own game that
we invented and no one could figure out
why and obviously Gareth himself has a
personal memory of what it is to miss a
penalty and then he broke that curse in
Russia in 2018 for the first time and I
think that was symptomatic of something
bigger going on culturally in the
English game he's quite political would
you say I don't know this I mean I think
he's on he's not afraid of the idea that
football can be more than just sport or
that a football player can be more than
just an athlete that they can represent
something they can be a role model and
when you look at anything from Marcus
rashford to what Raheem Sterling and
people have been doing finding a voice
and inserting themselves into politics
he's not afraid of that but to me my
growing understanding of Gareth is that
his Vibe is really he's an introvert
anyway and it's quite internal and what
he's trying to draw out of his players
is something bigger and if that's if
you're World experiences is you've
experienced racism then why can't the
game own that why can't you talk about
that if that's your life so he's yeah
he's yeah political the most prominent
expression of southgate's Revolution if
you like quite was was the team taking
the knee before games and it became this
woke political statement the minds of
some people and Lee Anderson now deputy
uh chair of the conservative party was
so incensed by this that he said he was
not going to watch the games and you
might sort of disagree with that James
but does do you accept that he speaks
for a lot of England the Lee Anson
doesn't that Southgate doesn't
well he's my M Paley Anderson from from
Ashfield and I I watched that happening
um I don't want to dismiss it because
like you said maybe there is a part of
the country that feels the same I think
it's interesting that he he was often
criticizing
the players for performative virtue
signaling and I equally think you could
accuse Lee Anderson of doing the same
that was quite a performative bit of
populist politicking he did just on sort
of
southgate's view though the racism that
Spilled Out after rashford Sacramento
missed those penalties in the euros and
they they did sort of dis reflectively
like a disconnect between southgate's
modern take on the game and how he saw
it and the reality of perhaps how
some of the fans did and the sort of
sickening attitudes of some of the fans
yeah we all remember that and it was
incredibly upsetting and disgusting and
I guess
a lot of that stuff we felt had been
have been buried some of those ghosts
and but they're always sort of there and
president and and I think what I find
um comforting and inspiring about that
moment though is how those basically
young Lads still those young men
took a breath took a moment and
collectively responded with such Grace
and such articulation and such decency I
think that is symptomatic of what is
going on in that team
the history of England often has been
one of these men not quite surviving
some of the incredible pressures that
are put on their shoulders the way they
articulated it was just really beautiful
we've written so many uh plays and
screenplays you're arguably Britain's
most celebrated political playwright and
screenwriter and did you set out when
you were at Asheville comprehensive
school to be who you have now become oh
my God no it's a big comprehensive
School in a poor area but for whatever
reason my Drama teacher decided that
working-class kids should do theater and
not have any stigma to it and and I just
fell in love I fell in love with
entertaining and storytelling and that's
why it was the genuine privilege of my
life to be able to do Sherwood last year
which was a story set in a red wall town
I think the red wall often is like a
it's like a black hole like a lot of
light and energy goes into it but very
little comes out of it do you think that
we focus sufficiently on class and do
you think we should be talking about
class more than we do we don't remotely
know how to talk about class
particularly in the Arts I think and I
think because we're squeamish about it
because we don't quite know how to
define it I get squeamish about it
talking about it now because I think am
I a fraud because I I know I Come From A
working class background but now I'm a
playwright with plays in the West End
and my income has changed from what my
parents was am I now no longer working
class therefore can you not have a
working class playwright and I think the
problem of definition is is part of it
um but you're right like even like bafta
has been a really incredible and really
brilliant
um in recent years about having a real
focus on underrepresented groups and
making sure the people that voters are
really aware of that they have my
sympathy with the fact that one of the
only metrics that they don't know how to
measure yet is class so it's not
mentioned when people vote for a film or
vote for a TV drama but bafta came into
a bit of criticism didn't it in the
because there was lots of ethnic
diversity in terms of the nominations
but actually what came out was I don't
think any ethnic diversity in terms of
winners right it was disgraceful it was
100 white winners and that is not
representative of the countries that are
making the art and I think I think I I
slightly feel for bafta I think I think
they would have been
confused and disappointed without
speaking on their behalf because they
have put real effort and systems in
place to make sure that underrepresented
stories get get more recognition but
there's still a human element that you
can't control and I imagine they're
gonna have to think about that talking
about should I want to talk as opposed
to their your hit TV series crime drama
I'm sure lots of people be excited to
know that the second series is coming
back well the second run like the first
be based on real life events it will be
inspired by things that have happened
yes so so the first series took
um it was inspired by some some killings
that took place in my Village a few days
down from where I lived and they even
though they were remotely politically
motivated
because of the the tensions and the
politics of a town ripped apart by the
miners strike 30 years previously people
projected onto it politics that weren't
there and it reopened Those Old Wounds
and I was living in the community at the
time and I really remember how upsetting
it was to see them that police return to
the community the same police force that
had tormented this town and and
exacerbated those divisions people were
really upset by that the season two's
come at a time when
industrial action with strikes in
schools and transport networks the NHS
and Beyond are so prevalent in our
national Consciousness will those
subjects feature in your next yeah
series I think so yeah well it was so
strange because obviously TV dramas take
a very long time to write and then
produce so I began the first series of
Sherwood about three years ago and I
couldn't believe actually that what
emerged during the production in the
broadcast about the last great National
strike was was this industrial action
which we've not seen on a scale since
obviously something is in the in The
Ether or the Zeitgeist and similarly I
think in particular
leveling up and Regional inequality and
and the lack of investment in the East
Midlands in particular uh will be a
political firework in the in the show
and in particular
um I can't believe this has happened but
obviously in relation to the real life
reopening opening of a brand new mine in
Cumbria uh one of the story points in
show world 2 will be a consultation
about reopening a pit in Nottinghamshire
and whether that's what the community
wants or is that just holding on to a
Heritage that's passed
so so it's going to feature the
reopening of a mind so it kind of ties
it implies the past to the present
exactly I think well I think what was
really um was really grateful for that
there were the the affection for the
first series seemed to be not about the
crime drama elements it was essentially
a story about community and how painful
it is when a political choice is
inserted into a community and divides it
and the minor strike was basically
pre-remain leave in terms of splitting
families and splitting friends and I
still find it very upsetting it's still
the case that people will cross the
street from someone who made a different
political choice or families brothers
and sisters can't speak to each other
because they were forced to make this
choice you have become a chronicler if
you like the red wall
um and it's a theme that as you say has
taken on huge political significant sort
of driven by Boris Johnson and red wall
and leveling up
and around brexit and about brexit being
this conduit in which there was an
argument that forgotten communities
thought this was a way of taking back
control to use the parlance of of Boris
Johnson do you feel that the community
you came from that these communities are
represented accurately in our political
discourse
no not at all and that's why I think
drama comes in because the tendency I
think in political discourse of course
is to imagining these communities is one
single homogenous block of uniform
opinion and in Ashfield there are you
know there's remain voters and leave
voters there are Working Class People
middle class people probably upper class
people that I've never met them
um there were liberals and there are
social conservatives and people are
complicated and contradictory and fluid
actually looking at the future of the
red wall do you think that political
events like partygate the cost of living
crisis the current strikes over public
set to pay do you think it will change
opinion again in seats like Ashfield
where Lee Anderson is now representing
your community definitely it definitely
cut through when I when I spend a lot of
time there
um now gloriously back with my family
and friends because of Sherwood and it
being said in that community and there's
no question in my mind that certainly
partigate cut through and
the feeling of Injustice that people
made sacrifices that it was it's
perceived that
um the people in power didn't so
something is changing and shifting I've
got no idea whether it will uniformly go
back to um to labor do you think Lee
Anderson is too ideological then for the
people of Ashfield because he doesn't
seem like a pragmatist to me I mean he
would definitely have his have his fans
but I also know people are people don't
necessarily enjoy
um the stirring I guess they would call
it someone who is who is who is um
deliberately trying to disrupt uh
something and there's um there's you
know my communities and places like them
there's a resistance to I think
show-offs people call them uh and
there'd be a sense of some people would
think he needs to wind his neck in a bit
and then focus more on on policy rather
on these culture wars and Lee would
disagree yeah and he would go look I'm
trying to represent the viewpoints of my
town all I would say to Lee is this
there is not a uniform consistent view
that comes from these places and you can
never claim to fully and completely
represent them because you'll only ever
be representing one will go labor again
next election then I genuinely don't
know but I think according to all the
polling it's going to be incredibly
close so I hope you'll be there in
Ashford I'd love to be there with you
well I and I'm looking forward to
watching uh your next play and your next
series of shows so thank you James for
seeing us today